79 percent of America's millionaires  airtight research data not a feeling not  a political agenda not your broke  brother-in-law's opinion at Thanksgiving  not how he feels about rich people none  of this data  79 percent inherited precisely zero wow  8 out of 10. five percent more inherited  a small amount like fifteen hundred  dollars or five thousand dollars  mathematically could not have possibly  made them a millionaire another five  percent inherited substantial money like  a hundred thousand two hundred thousand  dollars after they were already  millionaires so five and five and  seventy nine we're at 89 percent nine  out of ten of America's millionaires did  not become millionaires because of an  inheritance wow